without this TV show I'm nothing nothing
so I shouldn't even be here right now
I have so many episodes to watch you
don't understand because Game of Thrones
does things to me that My Little Pony
never could do but just because my
therapist says I was wooden
he says I'm bipolar
watch he says I'm eating disorders and
addictive behave what I'm offended
honestly he compares me to another
species bipolar not bipolar I don't I
don't believe in that arctica what is
waters and he says have addictive
behaviors and and I have an eating
disorder
really really really oh oh I'm a
therapist yeah and look at me I'm so
small smaller than you you have an
eating disorder
oh my god all I'll have a degree really
really real Matua honestly
real mature oh yeah like okay look look
I I have a fandom to satisfy I have to
watch every watch every episode of every
season of Game of Thrones and put a blog
post once a week minimum at least and if
this means I skip a couple dozen meals
what's so bad no no no no I'm fine
I don't need the men I don't need the
medication so so I can I can just take
this or I can just take this
okay